[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce magazine
d'elancourt à montigny le bretonneux de
saint germain en laye à la verrière les
seuls les saisons 2019-2020 se dévoile
dans ce premier numéro spécial qui leur
est entièrement consacré de la musique
du théâtre de la danse
huit salles yvelinoise nous présentent
leur rendez vous à venir et on débute du
côté est d'elancourt 42 date du 28
septembre au 15 mai le prix se poursuit
son orientation tout public la salle
propose une saison 2019-2020 tourner
vers l'éclectisme éclectisme des styles
éclectisme des âges le point sur les
principaux rendez vous
une saison qui démarre tout en douceur
le prisme fait sa rentrée le 28
septembre en mode cocooning
un premier rendez vous pour les enfants
de six semaines à deux ans et demi pour
cette nouvelle saison
dix dates sont destinés aux plus jeunes
on aura des choses aussi variées en
jeune public que par exemple un concert
de little rock story qui un concert
participatif pour les familles à la
découverte de tout le répertoire du
rock'n'roll tati jambon marianne james
voilà aussi avec un concert à dire est
que ce sont des petits et plus du cirque
en ouverture de saison spectacle
simplicité sur terre
des spectacles pour tous les âges une
présentation regroupant tous les styles
du jazz du classique ou de la pop
en mars c'est zazie qui marque l'un des
temps forts en comptant son essentiel
marche
et puis que ça quiron vérino et au qatar
ouedraogo elie semoun le prisme vous
invite à rire avec eux huit dates sont
dédiés à l'union à la comédie le monde
caractérise cette saison sait où les
deux mots c'est osé rentrer osé venir
prendre des éléments culturels osé venir
au théâtre
oser venir au cinéma oser venir dans un
lieu culturel le prisme europe dans
cette logique extrêmement diverses
éclectique avec toutes formes de
spectacles cultures qui cohabitent voilà
à l'image aussi la population l'idée
c'est que chacun puisse trouver un
moment donné un rendez vous culturel et
artistique qui qui lui corresponde qui
donne envie de venir aux prises à un
moment donné de l'année et s'il ne
fallait pas rater une date au prisme on
vous oriente vers une oeuvre moliérisé
la machine de turing revient sur la
personnalité complexe d'alan turing
l'inventeur de l'ordinateur moderne de
septembre à mai il y en aura pour tout
le monde à montigny le bretonneux avec
une quarantaine de rendez vous la ville
mise sur des valeurs sûres et la
jeunesse de patrick bosso à tom sawyer
la saison vous invite à rentrer tous en
scène à l'image du banquet de mathilda
may c'est une saison joyeuse et déchaîné
qui attend montigny le bretonneux avec
38 spectacles programmés la ville a
choisi de miser sur la surprise il ya
cette recherche en tout cas aussi de
pouvoir attirer un public plus jeune on
a aussi beaucoup misé sur du burlesque
cette année je pense notamment aux
banquiers
que mathilda may présenter elle-même
comme une oeuvre théâtrale non
identifiés des valeurs sûres et des
prises de risque du rire avec tables me
rachid bosso de la musique avec grand
corps malade et de la magie le roi du
transformisme arturo brachetti s'arrête
à la femme du manuel en février
la priorité c'est avant tout de faire
plaisir aux gens
avec expérience avec les années on sait
aujourd'hui ce que les gens ont comme
desiderata mais néanmoins ceci nous
empêche pas chaque année d'essayer de
mettre en place des spectacles
différents parfois surprenants c'est le
cas cette année et des moments d'émotion
aussi le 11 mars richard berry fait ses
plaidoiries et celle de grandes affaires
judiciaires du procès de bobigny à celui
de véronique courjault
on cherche le tap de la vérité c'est un
moment exceptionnel ya une prestation de
deux comédiens qui est absolument
extraordinaire
une mise en scène qu'il est tout aussi
des spectacles familiaux vont aussi
rythmé la saison la salle jacques brel
et la ferme du manet vous attendre dès
le 29 septembre pour une saison
éclectique partir à la découverte de
l'autre se connecter au monde mais aussi
à soi même avec ses 61 spectacle
programmé de septembre à juin la scène
nationale vous emmène à la rencontre des
artistes de tous horizons le nen masse
et à bonjour vous êtes le directeur du
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines et
avec votre nouvelle saison vous
souhaitez notamment faire découvrir des
artistes parfois peu connus du grand
public via les deux missions il est
notamment demandé voilà c'est cette
mission des dalles à la création cette
mission de suivi des artistes qui sont
un peu plus connus mais qu'on a suivi
depuis qu'on a découvert il ya quelques
années
et puis l'aide aux nouveaux venus parce
que je crois que le renouvellement des
générations artistique est important
mais il est aussi important de soutenir
les artistes qui sont déjà installés
dans la place alors dans les plus connus
on pourrait peut-être cité un certain
monsieur top bar c'est à voir en famille
ça se passe du 16 au 18 janvier 2020
ouais c'est c'est peu connu du grand
public et pourtant c'est une compagnie
absolument mythique le turak théâtre qui
a tourne depuis un peu plus de 20 ans
en france et internationalement ils ont
créé un monde qui s'appelle un pays qui
s'appelle la tuera qui est en fait
toutes leurs créations absolument toutes
leurs créations se passent en turquie et
en tueur à qui tout est possible
notamment le recyclage d'objets
usuellement utilisée au quotidien et 7,7
sur cette réutilisation en fait ce
détournement des objets nous fait voir
la turquie comme un pays totalement à
part alors que tout ce qu'on a sous les
yeux
est ce sont des choses que l'on a sous
les yeux quotidiennement est donc simple
peut-être avec un extrait on n'en doute
mais regardez leurs gardes
[Musique]
ça distrait
il
[Musique]
le kg
houasnia je pensais
[Musique]
ce sont les voyages away sont des
bricoleurs absolument génial et ils
construisent tout ce qui assure sa une
construit entièrement tout ce qu'il ya
sur scène dans ses formidables
alors la saison débute le 20 septembre
ça commence pas le 20 janvier chez vous
à la mise en scène il ya cyril testé sur
scène morgan lloyd sicard frédéric
pierrot une certaine isabelle adjani
quatre dates sont proposées pour une
oeuvre d'un ancien artiste en résidence
oui et surtout une une oeuvre d'un
artiste et on en parlait juste avant que
l'on ait découvert il ya une quinzaine
d'années un moment il ne tournait
absolument nulle paris avec 4,5 théâtre
qui l'accueillît parce que je pense
qu'il était aussi dans sa façon de
mettre en scène dans l'utilisation de la
vidéo certainement tout petit peu en
avance sur sur les autres artistes
donc on l'a accueilli moi j'ai accueilli
dans d'autres lieux dans d'autres
contrées il ya quelques années quand je
suis arrivé à saint quentin il a été
artiste associé et puis il a créé une
oeuvre qui s'appelle nobody qui a
énormément tourner ça a été un
déclenchement puis ensuite il enchaînait
avec festen une adaptation de festen et
là isabelle adjani a vu ses deux pièces
elle l'a contacté d'abord par facebook
et puis allez le voir en loge lorsqu'il
jouait à lille il a dit je veux
absolument travailler avec vous il a
hésité un tout petit peu et puis comme
c'est souvent le cas quand isabelle
adjani vous propose une collaboration
vous réfléchissez puis vous dit oui à la
fin et là ça va être une adaptation de
opening night qui est la pièce qui
d'abord une pièce de théâtre avant
d'être le film
mais culte de john cassavettes qui
tourne autour de jean à rolande gina
roulante et en étant concernés étant
utilisé temps regardez comme l'actrice
archétypale l'a7 l'actrice archétypale
autour de laquelle les caméras de cyril
test tourner c'est isabelle adjani et
c'est très surprenant tout simplement
parce que la pièce comme tous les soirs
de première en ce soir de première c'est
une instabilité une fragilité et bien
cette fragilité il la conserve tous les
soirs puisque chaque soir les scènes des
scènes peuvent changer des scènes
peuvent être intervertis donc quatre
présentations et quatre représentations
différentes et les spectateurs ne
peuvent donc réserver pour chacune des
représentations du théâtre on l'a vu
tout terre mais il ya aussi une large
page musicale 16 rendez vous programmé
paru mieux jana dead et kery james qui
rit james qui revient mais qui revient
et une fois de plus de façon atypique
c'est à dire que on l'avait programmé il
ya deux ans il me semble qu'il ya deux
saisons autour d'une pièce qu'il avait
écrite sa plaie à vif
là il était donc comédien il était
surprenant parce que l'écriture était
formidable sens le savez qu'ils savaient
écrire mais il savait aussi jouer élan
l'accueil non pas avec la grosse machine
derrière lui mais en concert acoustique
ce qui permet aussi de d'écouter
d'entendre totalement ses textes
donc ceux qui l'écoutent avec le gros
boom und der herr vont peut-être re
découvrir des textes ce qui pour qui le
rap c'est pas de la musique et ce n'est
pas l'écriture pourront venir se
convaincre du contraire
toutes les dates que vous proposez
certain nombre ont particulièrement
retenu votre attention
elles sont quatre on va commencer que la
première je passe on aura le temps de
faire les 4 c'est le collectif night
shot avec un titre de pièces très long
mais qui s'appelle l'attrait
bouleversante confession de l'homme qui
a abattu le plus grand fils de que
la terre ait porté pourquoi cette pièce
pourquoi cette pièce parce que le cette
pièce autour de l'opération je me
souviens plus comment s'appelle cette
opération qui a été l'opération pour
pour prendre et pour tuer ben laden
est est une façon de travailler sur la
façon dans la culture américaine est
toujours présente et nous nourrit c'est
à dire qu'on déteste la mairie qu'on
aime l'amérique
peu importe on est biberonné par la
culture américaine au quotidien donc
c'est à travers cette histoire là une
façon d'avoir un tout petit peu de
prendre tout petit peu de recul sur
cette question et surtout est ce que ce
sur quoi insiste c'est que il est
possible sur scène d'avoir du théâtre
d'action c'est assez rare et la ccc
c'est assez bluffant
la deuxième c'est un grand écart on fait
de l'opéra cette fois il s'agit de
narcisse est en train d'être créées par
marion pellissier et saint narcisse très
actuelle on y parle médias et réseaux
sociaux avec en parle de père en on se
projette on revient au dix neuvième au
18e et ben non il se crée encore des
opéras aujourd'hui la preuve puisque cet
opéra est composée par joséphine
stephenson compositrice anglaise
francour franco-anglaise marion
pellissier artistes jeunes artistes
associés metteuse en scène a écrit
livrés et mettra en scène cette cet
opéra qui par louis des réseaux sociaux
narcisse comment est ce qu on travaille
sur le mythe de narcisse qui lui-même
contempler son image voire la voyez
différemment comment aujourd'hui les
adolescents peuvent travailler sur leur
image à travers tous les réseaux sociaux
on est un peu pris par le temps mais
bien sûr il ya d'autres spectacles
il ya et c'est un sentiment aussi pareil
j'ai raccourci un petit peu le titre
c'est un problème social qui vous a plu
mais qui fait partie des 4e édition des
rencontres une cité elles reviennent
cette année on va parler de la ville de
demain et ses défis alors bien sûr on
peut pas tout présenté 60 ha ça fait
trop long et bien sûr on peut toujours
trouver sur le site théâtre skip world
merci lyonnais l'investisseur vend
maintenant par clé sous voie puisque la
saison fête un anniversaire les 10 ans
de l'espace philippe noiret dix ans au
rythme des projections des spectacles et
des expositions
deux fils rouges pour 2019 2020 l'humour
et des hommages musicaux des hommages à
des grands noms culturel il longtemps
barbara ou encore louis armstrong
du côté de l'humour c'est fabrice éboué
qui montera sur la scène clé sienne le
21 novembre
un bol du directeur de la culture de la
ville avant de découvrir un extrait d'un
coup de coeur de la programmation
réfugiés
et poétique l'histoire d'un vagabond qui
choisit un coin de rue comme refuge
provisoire
on voulait surtout choisir des thèmes
qui était qui peut qui parlait à tous
c'était un petit peu l'idée et puis bon
comme on est aussi un cinéma une idée
c'était c'était aussi de faire un lien
avec avec les films de noiret voilà et
puis un côté hommage voilà donc on a
choisi dommage musical de premier rang
match sera aussi à philippe noiret
voilà pour l'ouverture de saison le 21
septembre où il y aura la présentation
de la de la saison l'inauguration de la
nouvelle petite salle de cinéma qui a
été complètement refaite et puis on fera
pour la première fois un spectacle son
et lumière sur la façade de noiret
[Musique]
m
oui
[Musique]
e
de la musique actuelle venus des quatre
continents du cirque du théâtre pour sa
saison 2019-2020 la merise propair
propose une trentaine de dates des
habitués de déclic théâtre au coup de
coeur de la programmation une plongée
dans les rendez vous à venir des têtes
d'affiché pour tous les styles à la
merise de trappes la programmation
s'adresse à tous petits comme grands
amoureux de chansons françaises ou de
fado note nullité différents certains
écoutent du rock au dock du fado
d'autres voix la musique du monde et je
suis du reggae
du rock de la chanson française donc oui
donc notre formation se destine au
niveau musical le plus large possible de
la ronde amis de la musique classique
également c'est du côté de la musique
qu'on trouve le coup de coeur de la
programmation suzanne révélation de la
scène française qualifié d'incroyable
par la merise
je t'avais un passant
dans le monde est bon
oui
elle lancé la saison précédente les
goûter spectacle sont remis au programme
de la salle trappistes il lance même la
saison 2019 2020
le 5 octobre les spécimens présentent
une satire burlesque du monde du cirque
[Musique]
c'est une formule qui fonctionne et les
parents des enfants sont en demande donc
voilà ce qui est intéressant surtout
celles échanges et le travail qui est
mené
ce n'est pas seulement une diffusion il
ya un travaille également avec les
familles qui viennent assister au
spectacle et après un échange avec
l'arctique et des ateliers et c'est ça
qui est chouette elle les habitués
seront aussi de la partie les solistes
de la villedieu et déclic théâtre
rythmeront aussi la saison du cirque du
théâtre de l'humour mais aussi de la
danse les pokemon crew revient natra
pour une étape de tournée anniversaire
la compagnie fête ses 20 ans une saison
éclectique au théâtre alexandre dumas de
saint-germain-en-laye on vous accueille
pour la saison 2010 9 2020 en théâtre en
musique et en danse et pour découvrir ce
qui vous attend dès la rentrée nous
accueille au sein même du théâtre sa
directrice sophie bodin bonjour bonjour
alors la saison commence chez vous en
octobre avec une pièce qui a connu un
triomphe depuis sa première en 2010
alors reprécise la distribution a un peu
changé mais l'effet des textes de
matthieu delaporte et alexandre de la
patellière est toujours présent je parle
bien sûr du prénom exactement grands
films grand grand spectacle franc succès
public mais effectivement bernard murat
le metteur en scène a eu l'audace de
remonter ce spectacle avec florent peyre
notamment dans un des rôles principaux
et c'est vraiment un pari réussi les
comédiens sont bourrés d'énergie
prennent un plaisir immense à être sur
scène et l'effet surprise de ce prénom
reste tout à fait intacte même quand on
connaît très bien la narration pour
revenir le 26 avril exactement s'en
lasse pas tout à fait
des mots et leur portée mais chose dans
merde j'appelle mon fils comme je me
sens je suis désolé mais je n'ai pas de
cours de près non recevoir de quelqu'un
qui a fait ses enfants voilà avertis
[Musique]
alors en théâtre toujours on retrouve
aussi deux visages connus de la sixième
chaîne lionnel astier frédéric bouraly
qui eux cherchent à trouver de mensonges
et une vérité et donc pas très loin on
part très très loin ne cherchant jamais
à essayer de surprendre un conjoint que
l'on croit connaître par coeur
donc voilà ce couple d'une cinquantaine
d'années va se redécouvrir c'est assez
rocambolesque dans l'histoire et c'est
vrai que les deux comédiens sont
fabuleux également manque son coup de
coeur pour lionnel astier en bus sur
deux personnages complètement différent
la cabotine r1 pu pêcher alors il ya des
moments drôles dans votre saison 6 ont
mis aussi des moments très forts avec
une pièce sur la mémoire ou non et une
autre sur l'occupation leur l'occupation
avec un o majuscule exactement la
mémoire effectivement nous allons
retrouver patrick chesnais dans un grand
rôle avec tu te souviendras de moi qui
aborde le thème de la maladie
d'alzheimer
patrick chesnais incarne un grand
professeur d'université qui peu à peu va
perdre la mémoire il n'oublie cependant
pas l'homme qu'il est et qu'il a été
c'est une pièce extrêmement touchant
dans laquelle il joue avec sa fille
donc on aura également un franc succès
l'occupation à comprendre comme une
occupation mentale puisque romane
bohringer salle en scène interprète une
femme obsessionnellement jalouse de sa
rivale c'est un texte d'annie ernaux on
sait une plume féminine qui au scalpel
c'est un langage un peu cru mais rempli
d'autodérision également un très beau
spectacle avec une belle comédienne
alors on a parlé beaucoup de théâtre
mais alexandre dumas c'est aussi de la
musique avec là encore de l'éclectisme
tout à fait c'est vrai qu'on a accentué
la programmation musicale notamment avec
trois concerts qui est notre parcours
concernant les majeures c'est un nom que
nous avons trouvé pour caractériser de
cet événement ces trois rendez vous sur
forme de récital avec trois pianistes je
dirais jeune vingtaine d'années mais
déjà connu de par le monde un très grand
les grands ensembles et grands
orchestres des artistes qui ont été
repérés notamment à l'opéra national de
paris
qui s'arrêtent chez nous pour trois
dates c'est mais saignée par patrick
petit mais scène musicale de saint
germain en laye qui nous fait vraiment
l'honneur d'accueillir et de programmer
ces trois artistes à découvrir sous
forme d'un tarif préférentiel également
alexandre kots europe notamment ce sera
des nôtres au mois de janvier de la
musique du monde avec un coup de coeur
fatoumata diawara qui est une belle
actualité actuellement chanteuse
africaine originaire du mali qui mixtent
les somaliens avec du jazz du blues que
nous programmons avec la clé smac de
saint-germain-en-laye puisque nous
aimons découvrir ensemble des pépites
que nous proposons public
nous allons commémorer debussy comme les
années précédentes avec un petit format
concert-lecture mise en scène par didier
magne en début de saison mois d'octobre
puis avec l'orchestré des siècles avec
lesquels nous accueillons les grands
solistes de l'orchestré au mois de mars
à l'occasion vraiment à nouveau de
l'anniversaire de la mort de debussy
alors ça fait beaucoup de dates on va en
voir encore quelques unes ont essuyé
aussi de l'humour chez vous à pouvoir
rire il ya caroline vigneaux il ya max
dinde ou encore le mozart groupe qui
revient chez vous quatre ans plus tard
nouveau spectacle effectivement
triomphale il ya quatre ans chez nous on
a eu vraiment tous les âges dans la
salle ils reviennent pour leur nouveau
spectacle
l'humour est toujours aussi dévastateur
en même temps l'école et les musiciens
sont excellents musiciens donc on re
découvre toute la palette de la musique
classique mais comme à chaque fois les
violons deviennent des guitares on joue
au ping pong sur scène en appréciant les
grands compositeurs pour le rendre
vraiment à des coréens alors les
familles ne sont pas en reste bien sûr
vie et en décembre notamment on va
pouvoir rêver que le sable de lorraine
bio rennes c'est vraiment métriques
serait taxée c'est tout à fait magique
vous vous dites vraiment le juste mot
puisque leur haine bihorel inventa
dispositif tout particulier sur une
grande plaque de verre elle installe en
fait un simple filet de sable sur lequel
elle va dessiner des images fabuleuses
pour raconter des contes là s'est
projeté aussi sur grand écran et avec
très peu en fait elle nous emmène dans
un grand voyage c'est vraiment à
découvrir
la saison dernière vous accueillez
registre régis obadia pardon pour une
grande création autour de la reine
margot
est ce qu'il ya une autre création qui
est prévue cette année oui tout à fait
c'est vrai que s'il ya eu un vrai
engouement du public un pur pour ce
temps fort une résidence de six semaines
à saint germain qui était exceptionnel
et cette année en 2020 plus tôt nous
allons rendre hommage à jean yves roques
l'ormeau grand danseur étoile de l'opéra
de paris qui nous a quittés il ya trois
ans maintenant mais qui a été élève
1 et les phares au conservatoire claude
debussy de saint germain grande soirée
hommage parrainé par les danseurs de
l'opéra de paris et des grands
chorégraphes comme il isabelle at elle
notamment issus de l'école de danse
exactement qui sera présente parmi nous
donc on retrouvera des extraits des
grandes et grands des écritures
chorégraphiques gisèle roméo et juliette
mais également une petite création d'un
quart d'heure par les danseurs de
l'opéra pour lui rendre hommage ce sera
l'occasion de découvrir l'univers de la
danse et son excellence aussi puisque
vous pourrez interroger les danseurs sur
leur métier fait rêver alors on passe
maintenant à la question piège vous
programmé une cinquantaine de dates ou
est-ce que parmi elles gagnent un coup
de coeur une oeuvre à ne surtout pas
manquer alors je dirais en théâtre la
mouche
mise en scène par christian hecq
sociétaire de la comédie française
nous l'avions accueilli il ya 4 5 ans
maintenant avec un spectacle jeune
public d'un milieu sur les mers il a un
univers foisonnant particulier plein
d'inventivité et là vous connaissez le
film de cronenberg des années 80 il va
en donner une mise en scène les
répétitions vont commencer cet été et on
attend vraiment avec impatience le
résultat final puisque c'est voilà sept
tomes se transformera en mouche comment
rendre ça au théâtre c'est toute la
question mais je ne doute pas qu'il
trouvera des réponses
incroyable merci sophy bois alors la
saison du théâtre des débute le 9
octobre pour être sûr de ne rien rater
direction le site internet
une saison placée sous le signe de la
création au théâtre montansier près
d'une vingtaine d'oeuvres sont le fruit
d'une coproduction de la salle
versaillaise des créations de théâtre de
musique mais aussi de danse le point
avec sa codirectrice
andré et dorine spectacle visuel
étonnant trois comédiens jouent plus de
quinze personnages sans prononcer un
seul mot
le coup de coeur du théâtre montansier
c'est assez étonnant de se rendre compte
de quelle manière le théâtre visuel
permet de raconter une histoire sans
mots à versailles la saison débute en
septembre avec un habitué thomas fersen
revient au théâtre montansier pour une
création création le mot d'ordre
avec dix sept nouveautés le monde entier
outre de présenter les spectacles dans
le cadre de contrats de cession a
soutenu les compagnies financièrement
pour réussir à monter ses projets et
donc on s'est associés d'une parade est
très grand metteur en scène très repérer
et d'autre part à des artistes émergents
à qui on permet de réaliser leurs
projets et de monter leurs oeuvres des
mises en scène contemporaine d'oeuvres
classiques la saison sera rythmée par
molière william shakespeare georges
feydeau honoré de balzac ou encore
victor hugo nous on pense qu'au théâtre
c'est le lieu du texte et donc c'est
important de faire entendre ses pièces
par exemple ruy blas monté par yves
beaunesne que l'on coproduit avec les
mines et les fêtes nocturnes de grignan
on va entendre un grand victor hugo qui
n'est pas monté si souvent la scène
versaillaise accueillera aussi des
grands noms de la danse les italiens de
l'opéra de paris interpréteront
plusieurs extraits du répertoire de
l'institution jean claude gallotta
mettra en scène trente enfants de 12 à
17 ans le théâtre montansier connaîtra
aussi une nouveauté
[Musique]
une programmation aussi diversifiée du
côté de la verrière le scarabée ouvre sa
saison le 28 septembre avec une lecture
une exposition et un spectacle celui de
l'oukase à un trio de musiciens
passionnés par l'artiste barbara des
partenariats avec la mission danser les
itinéraires peau et ils vont aussi
rythmé la saison un nom de sa directrice
avant de nous intéresser au groupe qui
souffre qui fait l'ouverture
nous accueillerons tous les mois tous
les derniers samedis du mois des
lectures avec le tête du sable écoute en
famille
nous accueillerons toute l'année des
expositions et donc des spectacles de
chansons également puisqu'on garde la
veine de chansons de du scarabée de
musique du monde avec de la chanson
kabyle par exemple au mois de décembre
et puis et puis aussi une programmation
très éclectique avec également du
théâtre de la poésie et une saison de
spectacles jeune public également très
varié avec de la danse de la marionnette
tous les passants s'en sont allés mais
toi plus têtus que lapierre tu n'as pas
quitter la rivière ni la colline aux
fleurs de même
tu gardes le feu la table la rose et le
sirop d'érable comme au dehors des très
lourd secret
certaines saisons seront dévoilés à la
rentrée 2010 9 c'est le cas de la
lanterne la salle rambo liten vous
invite à la découverte de ces rendez
vous le 14 septembre prochain
c'est un samedi à 20h sont déjà connus
frédéric mitterrand il a belle car et
bernard campan dans la dégustation ou
encore rock voisine on acoustic
c'est la fin de ce site une culture
merci de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
mardi prochain pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]
là